Email is one of those potentially powerful tools that actually turns into an Achilles' heel if not managed.
A lot of us hit the "Send" button and ruin our careers,...
...wishing we could take back what we've just sent.
So here's a few rules of email that will lead to better living.
Rule number one. Never send an email when you're mad.
And if you want to know you're mad,...
...just take two fingers, close your eyes, touch your eyelids.
If they're hot, researchers say, you're mad and you should put it in the draft pile.
Send it later.
One of the things I've learned is that email is for saying yes.
Email is for answering and asking questions.
If you say no, if you criticize, if you attack, please do it in person.
Or at the worst case, do it over the phone.
Two more quick rules. Stamp out "Reply to all."
I call it the sortie campaign.
"Reply to all"" is considered arrogant.
It is considered unsophisticated, especially by younger workers.
Don't be lazy. Take the time to actually respond just to the people that need to get that email from you.
Never send emails to your subordinates after hours, on the weekends or during holidays.
When you send someone an email at three in the morning,...
...you're sending the following message:...
..."You should feel guilty when you go home next Tuesday at 7:30 for dinner."
If you have an inspiration off hours, write it, put it in the "Send later" pile...
...and send it during normal business hours.